[Music]
welcome everybody to session 76 of the
worlds of speculative fiction series
I'll tell you just a little bit about
what this series is in a bit but first I
want to highlight which books we're
looking at this month because this is
sort of a double header we're also going
to be doing this in the next session as
well looking at the next two books in
this series what are they well we've got
these two massive Toms by Stephen
Ericson uh both of which which are tals
of the malison book of the Fallen we'll
talk about that word Tale in just a
minute so we have Gardens of the Moon
the one that kicks it all off and then
we have dead house gates uh some overlap
in characters and narrative between the
two of them although the setting is a
bit different from one to the other and
we're talking about a very vast and
complicated world uh there's more to be
said about that as well but before we
get too far into this so what is Worlds
of speculative fiction this is a series
that we began in 2016 originally in
person although we video recorded the
sessions it was hosted at the Brookfield
Public Library here in the greater
Milwaukee area and people would come and
we would I would present a bit about
author text stories narrative
philosophical themes then we'd get into
discussion and sometimes the discussions
could go quite far a field and it's
anything in speculative fiction I tend
to pick most of the authors but
eventually we got to the point where we
started having the audience also give
suggestions and then we vote on it each
year so um what are what is the focus it
is on World building a common narrative
universe that is spread across multiple
short stories or in this case novels and
High text there are 10 in this
particular series not counting prequels
right so we're only going to be looking
at the first two and you can tell both
of these are already pretty long stories
uh on their their own so we talk about
some of the key characters some of the
author's insights into their own process
sometimes we look at reviews of their
work what other people have had to say
about it we're going to get into that a
bit as well so we started out as I said
at the Brookfield Public Library
eventually we shifted during covid to
this format that you're seeing right now
where I will present um anywhere from 90
to 120 Minutes depending on you know how
how deep we want to go and how much
there is to cover there's going to be a
lot with with these too and then we have
some discussion so some of the
discussion actually takes place while
the video is airing for the very first
time if you're watching this in the
premiere you get to uh use the chat
function and we will go back and forth
and have communication with each other
about key ideas and Ericson and the
whole world of
malisan actually the world Malazan is in
Malazan is an Empire within that world
and only a part of it and then we have a
zoom session afterwards so some live
video conferencing if you're watching
this after the premiere you could can
still comment and be involved in it and
we do this every month uh as best as we
can we've got a whole great lineup set
for the next year already and we'll
probably continue this for years to come
because there's so many great authors so
speculative fiction that includes
fantasy which is what these are science
fiction horror weird Tales um alternate
history magical realism
nonsense stories we could say
philosophical humor as well and all the
blends of these in between and some
other things uh on the side so uh what
are we going to be doing we're going to
be delving deep into these two volumes I
do want to say something uh at the start
before we kick everything off we'll talk
about the World building but I want to
talk about the structure of this
narrative and the density of it because
a lot of people find it quite daunting
so that is where we're going to begin
and then we we've got a lot of other
great stuff to cover so settle back if
you've got a snack or some popcorn or
whatever it is you're going to enjoy uh
take a you know a seat we're going to
make our way in a Long March not quite
military like the the Malon people here
but we're going to March through these
text and see what they have to say to
all of
us in these sessions we usually Dive
Right into something right off the bat
maybe World building or biography or
something else but this time around I
think it's really quite important for me
to address
something
that stems from what other people are
saying about the malison book of the
Fallen Novels namely that they are so
difficult to read and understand and
make sense out of what's going on so I
myself have been told ah you're probably
not going to be able to figure out
what's really happening until you've
read the third novel and you know that
would be pretty problematic given that
we've only gone through these two at
this point lot of people are saying oh
you better you know bookmark the malz on
Wiki because you're going to need it so
much for everything in order to make
sense out of what's Happening you know
Ericson doesn't engage in any Exposition
or World building he doesn't hold your
hand as a reader and help you into his
world and you know like a lot of things
that people say about literature that's
pretty hyperbolic meaning that's
overplaying their hand a bit now I will
say that I can't definitively tell you
that with every single character every
single location every single plot twist
I fully understand every single thing
that's happening in these two books on a
first reading but I did not find the
difficulty that was advised to me I
better be on the the lookout for and be
ready for in going into Gardens of the
Moon nor did I find that with dead house
gates and I will say that this is helped
out
significantly by the fact that there are
some you know very small appendices you
could call them given in these texts
under dramus personi now in this this
newer copy that I've got it's at the
very front of the book which is probably
the smartest place to put it in the the
older one I had it it was well it is
actually at the end in the glossery as
well and so you know there's only a few
pages but I think that's quite enough to
make sense out of at least some of the
things that are going on and there's a
little bit of expansion I think in the
dead house gates one as
well I will say this it is a story where
with with Gardens of the Moon you are
thrown right into the middle of it and
you kind of have to figure out what is
going on by putting things together
through illusions that are being made
sometimes you have to revise what you
were thinking about a particular
character a people a history because
because it's revealed that there's more
to the story as the tales go on right
and it is a very complicated tapestry
that is woven there's a lot of point of
view characters there are a lot of
different locations there are many
different let's call them by the
traditional term factions at odds with
each other or colluding with each other
trying to use each other other trying to
get information from each other but this
is the good news for readers it's not
something that's insurmountable nor that
you actually have to wait until the
third book to be able to make sense of
or understand that is clearly not the
case and while it may be helpful to go
to the Meson Wiki or to other sites that
tell you something about like the races
or the peoples or the backstory or the
characters or the Warren or the cards or
pick whatever else you
want I don't think that that's actually
necessary in order to piece together and
to appreciate the ongoing complicated
tale that's being told
now I mentioned this in social media
after reading through Gardens of the
Moon and a lot of people were like well
you know you're somebody who teaches
philosophy and can unpack you know
hegel's phenomenology you do that for a
living so obviously you're an outlier
and the average reader is going to have
much more difficulty than you and I will
certainly grant that right I think that
perhaps by the types of works that I
tend to study as well as what I consume
in literature maybe I'm a little bit
better equipped for that but I don't
think that I'm radically different than
any intelligent reader would be so if
you are one of these people who's heard
how tricky how complicated how murky and
obscure these Ericson uh malison books
are don't worry about that dive in and
see what you actually think of them what
what you make of it you know don't take
other people's word as like the gospel
truth about it it doesn't say you have
to dismiss what they have to say
especially if they've been down the path
and you haven't but it would be smart to
put that those worries those
preconceptions aside and just dive into
this incredibly complex world and see
what you can actually make of it you may
have to go back and reread you may have
to turn to the glossery and be like all
right what is going on here here that's
perfectly fine but you know I think that
any intelligent reader should be able to
get quite a lot out of the very first
reading of these two Malazan
novels The Narrative Universe of these
two first of the Malazan Book of the
Fallen Novels is
incredibly vast and rich in a number of
different dimensions
so we better spend a bit of time looking
at very broad patterns Dimensions
whatever we want to call them aspects of
the World building that is going on
primarily in these these two volumes
obviously there's more to say as we
proceed through the series but I'm going
to try to stick to what we have just in
these because I mean you can tell by
looking at the size of these it's
already quite a lot and I do want to
point out certain features of these
books that you might want to check out
so you know one of them is the world
itself and each of them does contain
maps of where the action is taking place
so U Gardens of the Moon gacis which is
an entire continent and then um Dar
ristan which is of the main locations
that's the key City involved in it dead
house gates is on a different continent
that of the Seven Cities and so we have
uh maps of that as well um so we get you
know colan's March the first half the
second half some rather detailed maps
and then we also have dramus Persona the
you know key characters those are pretty
length y there's a lot of people
represented in these stories and we'll
talk about that in just a minute and
then at the end of each of them we have
we have a glossery which is quite
helpful as well that includes um you
know place names the world of sorcery
titles and groups the deck of dragons
which we'll get to in just a bit
different uh peoples ascendants you know
and so there's there's a lot of
information being conveyed there and it
may be very helpful for the reader to
have that uh available at hand there is
of course the Meson Wiki that you can
look all these things up in as
well so what do we want to say about
this world to begin with it is a vast
world right there are number of
continents many of which we're not going
to see until the later books there is no
absolutely definitive map of the entire
world although there's there's you know
quite a few out there that Ericson has
said yeah these are pretty good um and
it is not only a vast world
spatially it's also a vast world
temporally or historically we could say
so as opposed to our
world which you know as far as we know
um we are the
sensient species that arose and then
came to dominate this planet effectively
I mean there's other pretty smart
species but none of them develop
technology or culture in the way that we
did this is a world in which humanity is
a major race but a fairly new race and
there are far older races remnants of
which which are still left which made a
major impact on the world that um the
characters and events are taking place
in it's also an incredibly
complex and Rich world as well many
different cultures important
cities literature
backstories all of that sort of stuff is
woven into this and in ways that are not
always that easy to follow and which are
often provided in a
fragmentary way I'll also say that we
have you know I mentioned the dramus
Persona we have a vast number of point
of view characters and then many other
characters who are being glimpsed
through those characters eyes and you
know you might actually need the dramus
Persona just to keep track of Who's Who
and sometimes their loyalties will
change or they'll be revealed as not
being exactly who we thought they were
and it's it's one of the really standout
features of this work that there are so
many
interesting characters who are being
sketched out uh we learn about their
motivations we see their interactions we
see their history we see what they learn
on the way
way and we can say that to use an old
metaphor there are wheels within Wheels
within Wheels right everything is this
very complicated web of conflicts and
alliances and working with people and
Revelations so that's part of what is
happening here as I mentioned
geographically it's a pretty vast World
there are some you know oceans and
continents
um the ones that we're concerned with in
these two books are
primarily um that of the uh gabachas
which is where most of the action in
Gardens of the moon is taking place the
Seven Cities which is on part of a vast
continent but the continent itself is
often called The Seven Cities even
though it includes much more than that
in dead house gates but we also learn
about uh the home of the Malazan empire
quantal being discussed as a place in
this as well and you know we should
mention one other continent um the FI
Isles which some of the characters hail
from so that's only part of the world
that's eventually going to get sketched
out in later novels in it and I
mentioned that we are only one we humans
only one of the races that are involved
in this big long story so there are what
are called the founding races and we
don't really know that much about them
in these two books we get little
Snippets of
information um the one that we probably
learn the most about are the um imas
which become thean imas they were uh one
of the races that decided to engage in
genocide and wipe out one of the other
races that we'll talk about just in in a
moment and so in order to do that they
underwent a ritual that effectively
transform them into Undead
Warriors who could make it through
glaciers and hunt down the the second
race the jaghut uh we actually get to
see a jut Tyrant towards the end of
Gardens of the Moon a very
powerful uh type of creature and we meet
another uh jog as well in dead house
gates icarium who has lost his memory
due to what he actually did in his
lifetime and who's accompanied by a
trell one of his his close friends who
is sort of his keeper but there are two
other races as well we hear about the
folr um as ail and we don't learn much
about them in this and then there's a
yet even older uh original race the
cachen chimal and we're not going to
learn much about them at all except for
the fact that they had technology that
is still in use so in um Gardens of the
Moon the moon spawn is something that
apparently they created at one time so
we've got these other races and then
there
are other races besides those uh there
were dragons and we get to see one of
these original dragons the elain and
then we have the Tista Andy we see quite
a bit of them in this story The Children
Of Darkness they often called they have
you know uh dark skin and they are not
human they came out through these
magical Warren and um they are ruled as
much as you can rule them by uh an
ascendant on amander rake uh who is sort
of their you know great leader King uh
very strong scary guy who can actually
take the form himself of a dragon and
talk to dragons um
and the Tia Andi are fighting along with
the war Lord kaladan brood against the
Malazan with an alliance of others as
well and we get hints of there being
other T in Garden of the Moon and then
we find out about them a bit more but
not that much in dead house gates the
Tista edor who are gray skinned we
actually find about find out about them
because there are Tia Andi and tia edor
on this um let's call it a magical boat
where their heads have been cut off and
their heads are still Undead alive and
they are rowing the the boat when
commanded to to do so so those are
non-human races there's other non-human
races as well of you know sort you could
say lesser stature and then there's all
these different human cultures and
cities and they're often fighting with
each other they have their own different
uh
religions and uh political
organizations and doing what it is that
they're doing some of them are nomadic
some of them are settled and have been
you know in places forever and they've
they have all sorts of walks of life as
well as you can expect so here we ought
to talk about the Malazan Empire so
these are you know tales of the Malazan
Book of the
Fallen where we begin the story is with
the Malazan armies in both of these
books right well I mean technically
speaking that's not quite correct
because we have the the uh possession of
this uh girl who becomes sorry and then
uh takes on a different name after she's
no longer possessed right
so but the the main action that's going
on is the Malazan military and we have
all sorts of other people from this
Empire and at first it reads as if okay
this is the you know totalitarian evil
empire trying to take over everything
and we've got these soldiers which
include you know Mages you know magic
users and sappers all sorts of other
people including spies as well and
assassins um and they're all caught up
within the workings of this vast you
know not just bureaucracy but but you
know
military um Empire that's taking over
everything and then the other people are
trying to resist it but we actually find
out as the story precedes this is not a
Empire that's been around a very long
time and there are are other
organizations that are kind of big and
scary too that are just being hinted at
not fully revealed at this point in time
but we're going to get to see them in
the later novels now the other peoples
in these continents are not cool with
being taken over by the Malazan Empire
which is able to when it conquers a
place it's kind of like the old pattern
that we see in the Persian Empire and
the Roman Empire you know they're not
going to impose any sort of official
religion uh you pay your taxes we'll let
you keep some of the people in place but
if you Revolt we're going to crush you
and you know you'd better uh toll the
line so to speak right not cause trouble
and then they use the places that
they've conquered as grounds to draw New
Soul soldiers from so a lot of the
soldiers are not from the original malz
on let's call it Homeland they're from
all over the Empire the Malazan Empire
is quite good at taking people who were
originally opposed to it and
incorporating them into that Empire and
so this provides us with an incredibly
interesting backdrop for war for
Conflict for power for ADV Ventures for
all sorts of other things that are
taking place we should mention that the
Empire includes not just an emperor or
Empress in this case the empress is Lain
who is supposed to have assassinated her
predecessor uh kellanved uh and Dancer
his his Mage and assassin who came up
with him and we find out that Kellen Ved
was the
originator of this Empire first he took
over an island along with dancer and
then he began spreading the Empire to
all sorts of other places
including um taking on let's call it
possession or rulership of some of the
tan imas Undead Warriors who he could
use and then Laine by the time that the
action begins in Gardens of the Moon
has been in power for a while but not
actually that long and the Empire is
still making progress in conquering but
things are actually getting quite thin
in Gardens of the Moon the main
opposition is coming from uh these these
cities along with um uh kaladan brood
and anander rake and as we're going to
find out some let's call them
Supernatural elements as
well and um what we have is a very
complex power structure that includes as
main characters adjuncts the adjuncts uh
there's two of them one in in one book
one in the other are sort of second in
commands standin on the spot for the
emperor
uh and then we have high fists who are
military governors of very large re
regions with fists underneath them as
military commanders um the um main
action in dead house gates will actually
be as you know it's called the chain of
dogs led by the fist colaine who himself
had fought against the Malazan Empire
and then became one of the military
commanders in it uh we also
interestingly have another order which
is you know sort of like you could call
them their their CIA right their uh
covert operations group assassins and
mages working together to
undermine uh problematic powers and
these are called the Clause we later
find out in dead house gates that the
Clause replaced a earlier group um
associated with dancer the talons right
and they they fought against each other
so we've got this vast Empire but we
also have all this other cool stuff
being narrated there's an uprising in
dead house gates the Whirlwind a
rebellion against the Malazan Empire
that is going to sweep them from that
continent and you know liberate these
people but perhaps also put put them
under a different yoke as
well now I mentioned other powers right
so this is another really really key
dimension of this world this is a world
in which magic works but although it's
got a very complex and Rich conception
of magic and its workings the system if
you will is never fully sketched out it
is connected
with things called Warren which are not
the only source of magical power but one
main source of magical power most human
beings can only access one Warren some
people like one of the main characters
Ben can access multiple ones and um
these are locations within a magical
space that can emerge into the world
that uh maloon is is taking place within
and some of these are very very old like
the Warren of chaos which connect up
with the the other Warren um and we
actually get a whole listing of the
different Warren those that can be
accessed by human beings um you know
corresponding to different houses and
different
matters so we have for example you know
the Warren of denu the path of healing
the Warren of uh manyas the path of
Shadow and illusion Hood's path the path
of death but we also have other Warren
like um staral de dealan uh the tiam
Warren the first Warren right not
accessible by humans typically uh we
have others that are Warren for you know
the tan imas or the ti Andi or the
jagot so each of these is a a source a
locust of magical power that can go
places that can take you places that has
characters of its own and Magic is done
in significant part by accessing by
opening one's Warren and there's a whole
variety of Mages from you know the
lowest you know Squad Mages and other
magic users witches warlocks all the way
up to high Mages that might be in charge
of an entire army or you know particular
leaders might be Mages as well assassins
are sometimes themselves Mages and
objects can be magical for example the
the sword that um one of the characters
carries in Garden of the Moon pan is the
the character who does does that so
we've got all this stuff going on as
well and interestingly this is an equal
opportunity Universe men and women
various races can all access
magic it's all about figuring out the
connections so there is no like
automatic hierarchy involved in that and
it leads to a different world we also
have the ascendants or Gods people who
become powerful not just politically but
in terms of magic but also we could say
in terms of force of will and
character can become powerful beings and
so this is where a lot of the gods have
come from and the gods mess around in
not just human but all the other races
Affairs on this this world as
well Gods can be quite recent as we're
going to find out and many of them are
associated into particular houses Each
of which has its Warren and its own sort
of
organization so I'll just read you the
the names of these now these are from
the deck of dragons which replicate the
different houses so we have high house
Life High House death High house light
High House dark High House Shadow which
is also quite important and High House
Shadow is one that has been around but
hasn't done an awful lot until fairly
recently and High House Shadow has two
characters in particular Shadow house
the ruler of High House Shadow who is
along with the Rope or catian the
Assassin of High House Shadow opposed to
the Malazan Empire and trying to do
everything they can to undermine
it so that's a very interesting feature
as well there's a lot of monkeying
around on the part of the Gods one of
the gods that plays a really important
role in
Gardens of the moon is oppon the twin
gestur of chance one of the gestur is
male one of the gestur is female
embodied in a spinning coin that uh
crocus you know a a young Thief who has
a very important Uncle who unfortunately
will die by the end of Gardens of the
moon in the uh key city of this um which
uh here we go Daran gets repres
presented by this particular map it's
kind of a a cool you know CD place right
um that is one of the
interventions of these ascendants or
gods and ascendant can be killed a
sentence can be
destroyed and we're actually going to
find out not so much in the first novel
but in dead house gates there are also
these azath houses that develop we we do
actually get an azath house towards the
end of Gardens of the Moon a new azath
house where power is reckless and
unchecked and could destroy things these
houses arise and one of them is in fact
the dead House of the Dead house gates
on the island where you know the Malazan
Empire begins so these are prisons of
power they're all connected to each
other through its own Warren which
allows travel between these and so
that's another key feature of this world
as well I've already mentioned the
houses um the houses are you could say
factions of these ascended or Divine
beings and there are others who are
attempting to ascend as well so we
should mention there are shape shifters
called solot taken which are the ones
who turn into a single uh often
terrifying thing giant sea serpents
Bears dragons things like that and uh
divers which can turn into hordes of
things spiders rats all sorts of other
uh kinds of pack creatures as well and
then we also have in how Shadow the
hounds of Shadow which are these
terrifying gigantic wolflike dogs that
uh hunt at the command but are probably
o much older than the master of the the
house of shadow um Shadow Throne
himself so this gives you an idea about
the world that we're looking at we
haven't yet gone into any sort of plot
points or philosophical themes but at
least now you got a sense of the
vastness of the world that
are uh sort of hinted at again you know
there's so much to this and uh a lot of
it is dealt with in a rather fragmentary
way in these two
volumes when it comes to Steph Ericson
or as he was known before that Steve run
London much of his biography is actually
a listing of the books that he has
written and published at various points
in time there's not an extensive
biography pertaining to all sorts of
personal matters although there are many
interviews out there so he's Canadian he
was born in Toronto in 1959 which makes
him you know 64 at at this time and um
he grew up in Winnipeg another important
Canadian city attended the University of
Victoria eventually earned his degree in
archaeology and anthropology and did a
lot of work in North America and in
Central America as well working for
about 18 years in the field and
continuing to do digs from time to time
he also attended the Iowa Writers
Workshop which is a pretty important and
prestigious place to to go and it's
great for making contacts learning how
the business Works he met and married uh
Claire Thomas and they have uh one child
Bowen who is now in college himself and
another very important person in his
life is his friend Ian Cameron esselmont
who he uh in the 1980s began and
collaborating on something that would
eventually become mizon and it's worth
noting that there are two authors within
the Malazan narrative Universe both
Erikson and esselmont have written books
but it originally started out as a
setting for Dungeons and Dragons around
1982 and then they
shifted it to a different role playing
game system that was becoming quite big
at the time the gerps that came out from
Steve Jackson games which originally was
known for little card games and then Car
Wars if you remember your tabletop games
from the past and then they came out
with this generic Universal
roleplaying system that would take
whatever you wanted really and and allow
you to turn it into stuff and even like
have
crossover um you know from this this
particular system to this one so they
started building out malison this
incredibly Rich world within that as a
place where you could play and you know
it's interesting because Erikson will
mention that um you know roleplaying
games were actually a major influence
along with a whole bunch of other
authors for the development of this um
this series this world this this whole
conception his first books were not
actually within this fantasy
series he's uh given a grant to to work
on his master's thesis and part of that
will be uh his first no you know story
cycle a ruin of feathers which is
published in
1991 he begins starting writing Gardens
of the Moon around that time originally
he and um his friend uh esselmont had
conceived of that as a movie script but
they were unable to find anybody who
wanted to produce it which is probably a
good thing given the complexity of it
it's you know there have been talks of
adapting this material but but you think
about the successes and much more often
failures of adapting fantasy literature
and sci-fi literature for that matter to
the big screen or to the television and
the prospects are probably not great for
a series this complex he publishes um
several other novellas and and novels in
the
1990s um stolen voices uh in 1995
they move to the UK he begins working at
Toyota and their Communications division
in 1998 he publishes two Works uh um
revolvo and other Canadian tales and a
novel this River awakens and then by
1999 he has
successfully developed out Gardens of
the Moon into the shape that we find it
now and and it gets published in 1999
and it's a an overnight sensation you
could say it gets a lot of traction
especially on fantasy sites and we're
talking about the early years of the
internet at that point and that might be
partly responsible for the you know not
the success of the novel but the the
extent of its success because people can
talk with each other and and you know
this is a very important feature of
things and then something really
interesting
happens it's published by a company
called
Transworld
and once it's a success he gets another
offer from another company uh Orion and
then Transworld makes him an a counter
offer and it becomes one of the largest
advances up until that time uh
675,000
British pounds offer to write the 10
book series now of course they didn't
give him the entire Advance upfront it's
going to be sort of you know rolled out
over time but this was a very
significant uh amount of money that
allowed him to quit working at Toyota
and just write full-time but by this
time he is actually uh really you know
developed as a writer so a 10 book
series is certainly something
conceivable and I'm just going to run
through the books and the dates so in
the malison universe now remember this
is just the books that um that Ericson
himself is writing esselmont is also
writing books in this narrative universe
but we won't talk about those so uh 1999
we've got Gardens of the Moon 2000 dead
house gates 2001 memories of ice an even
longer book than those two 2002 House of
chains
2004 midnight Tides now you notice the
the it's slowing down a little bit but
still you know pretty massive books
coming out every two years 2006 the bone
Hunters 2007 Reaper
Gale 2008 toll the
hounds 2009 dust of dreams and
2011 bringing the series of malaz on the
house of the Fallen but not the
narrative Universe to a close the
crippled God so that's 10 books brought
out over the course of 12 Years pretty
amazing uh that that productivity there
and that's not all of the Malazan books
that Erikson wrote there's also Elmont
as we pointed out there is the uh
caronis Trilogy which is about the tisy
uh races 2012 we have Forge of Darkness
2016 fall of light and he's still
currently working on walk in Shadow so
those are about this earlier race these
are prequels and then there's the
witness Trilogy which is still ongoing
as well in
2021 uh the God is not willing came out
he's currently working on no life
Forsaken and then we have a a series of
novellas that are Tales of B uh Balin
and uh corbal brooch and these are
coming out from 2002 to
2020 and it's interesting because the
books that he is writing and esselmont
are writing they overlap to some extent
as a matter of fact they've actually
come up with and you can find this
online a suggested order of readings
that includes all of those books by
Ericson as well as all of esselmont
maloon series books as well so he's
still a living writer and he's still
occasionally doing archaeological work
the last dig out in Mongolia there were
some problems with that but he's he's
still quite active and they've moved you
know they moved back to Canada uh and
then back to the the UK again and so
he's a very productive writer uh stays
engaged in conversations online with
interviews at cons and apparently is
quite accessible to his fans so quite an
interesting thing we can expect more
malison novels coming out but
fortunately as far as this particular
thing goes the malison uh book of the
Fallen is finished and you know we're
going to be primarily focusing just on
these two early ones from the end of the
last century and the beginning of this
one I think that when we're fortunate
enough to have the wealth of interviews
that we have with an author like Stephen
Erikson we may as well take advantage of
them they provide us insights into how
he understands and he thinks about his
own Works in particular these two
novels uh of the 10 of the Malazan Book
of the fallen so there's a lot of cool
things that we can delve into we're only
got to kind of scratch the surface in
this but there's a couple where I think
we do have to drill down so we're going
to begin with this fantasy Hive
interview from
2018 where Erikson has asked when you're
creating something as complex as Malon
book of the Fallen how do you go about
planning something that massive and
Ericson says you know what I look back
on it and I literally can't remember how
I pulled that off I started Gardens of
the Moon in 1991 or 1992 and I wrote the
draft I couldn't get a publisher living
in Canada at the time and even then I
sort of had in my head where this is
going to go and there were going to be
10 books in all which I knew wasn't ever
going to I wasn't ever going to bring up
when pitching the project we initially
pitched it as a
Trilogy just I didn't want to scare
anybody away because you know you make
the promise as an unproven writer and
it's a pretty major promise but I had
scenes that were towards the end of the
10th novel sitting in my head for 15
years so then it was a question of well
what do I have to do to be patient
enough to take my time getting there
because if I wanted any sort of
emotional context to those scenes as I
felt viscerally when I had them in my
head I had to sort of prepare the reader
and in some respects it took almost all
10 novels to prepare the readers for
those final scenes and I had immense
ambition at the time and was driven very
driven once I'd gotten the green light
for the 10 book series there was really
no stopping me and there was even a fear
of dying before I could finish it I
remember being struck by a quote I read
somewhere when Robert Jordan when is in
his last few years at a signing where he
signed a book for an elderly woman who
expressed a fear of her dying before he
finished the series and of course the
bitter irony being Jordan himself dying
before he could finish the series and
the closer I got to it there was a
disastrous decision decision to do some
archaeology in Mongolia between books at
9 and 10 and then almost killing me from
a stomach bug and then a spider bite it
just started getting ridiculous then I
realized if I killed over in Mongolia
between book N9 and 10 wherever my
gravestone was in the world people would
annually piss on it so I thought okay I
got to get this thing finished I came
back I was living in Falmouth at the
time so I came back to Cornwall and just
rote my ass off and got it done so fear
can be a driving force in the
things and then he's asked you created
the world with Ian esselmont who's also
written his own series set in the same
world what's it like sharing your baby
with another writer and he
answers well it's like two parents
sharing a baby you equally contributed
to whatever genetic progyny you produce
so if you look at my dedication to
Gardens of the moon it's basically to
Ian ement worlds to conquer worlds to
share and I'll just you know show you
that right there right um when I said
that I was saying that to reassure him
because nobody else knew he was going to
step forward and write some Mala on
novels but I wanted him to be very clear
it was a shared world as far as I was
concerned and the door was open for him
so he picked that up and dropped the PHD
he was doing at the time and had to
rethink his future and I'm so pleased
that his latest Trilogy origins of
Empire is doing so well he seems to have
found his stride in terms of the
narrative length and he's just clearly
having great fun writing that stuff and
that's the stuff we actually gamed so
that's a lot of fun for
me I get to tap in and see what he's up
to and how he remembers things versus
how I remember things and then how these
things change for the purposes of
fiction it's a lot of fun now I think
that's very telling and interesting it
shows a sort of
generosity and friendship that some
sometimes comes through in characters in
these novels particularly I would say
mimicked a little bit in dead house
gates with the two Elder races uh
characters one of whom doesn't quite
remember his own past the other of which
guides him around in friendship now I'm
not going to say that that's a direct
parallel but you could easily think of
other writers not being willing to share
their Universe like that the Universe of
these books of the Fallen is so rich and
vast that it admits of somebody else
working with that same stuff somebody
else who kind of has a right to do that
in juston MO
interview
2018 he's asked dead dead house gates
like Gardens of the moon is about a
rebellion for the first one you chose
the perspective of rebels and for the
the second one we have the opposite
perspective with the wicens in a certain
way did dead house gates uh be
considered as an answer to Gardens of
the Moon and and Ericson says yes I
suppose in some ways what we gained of
course was the creation of the Malazan
Empire and that was the foundation for
the novels but no Empire is monolithic
in terms of its point of views normal
lives are caught in the currence of
their lives and history they may not
agree but they're being pulled Along by
that current an Empire like anything
else like a country for example will
have diverse points of views opinions
and even sensibilities regarding loyalty
the idea for the second novel was how to
look at how even a large war or
Rebellion eventually reduces down to a
soldier beside you and that was kind of
the approach to dead house gates now
he's asked as well
after Gardens of the Moon you left
gabachas and Whiskey Jack to go onto
another continent with three of your
characters why didn't you stay on
gabachas for the second book so Ericson
says well there's a bit of a story
behind that after finishing my first
draft of Gardens of the Moon I started
on what would become memories of ice I
thought that was the second book back
then we didn't have computers the way
they are now I was using a word
processor that had a floppy disc that
could only contain in all 64 kilobytes
of memory so I needed multiple floppy
discs to build a novel and I lost them I
was about 350 pages into memory of ice
and I lost them all I was so
disappointed I thought I can't sit and
start rewriting now 350 pages so I put
that story aside and Wrote dead house
gates which became the second novel it's
entirely by accident that the order of
the three books is what it is isn't that
fascinating to learn in NE neoplus uh
interview uh we find he's asked in the
past I've seen you mention stylistic
changes that were at the Forefront of
revisions you made from Gardens of the
Moon to subsequent novels I was
wondering if you can describe this
progression personally as a writer and
what would you point to as the chief
difference and influences to that change
from that book to dead house gates so
Ericson said
in many ways I approached Guardians of
the Moon as I would any fiction project
i' had been schooled in the non-emotive
style prevalent and contemporary fiction
I wrote in the style of he said she said
rather than he she graded growled his
Etc and where I use such descriptive
add-ons they were once removed in a
sense this didn't fit with the genre
style readers pursuing a heightened plot
with Adventure and excitement foremost
in their minds are used to a fully
delivered emotional content to dialogue
a stylistic shortcut the kind that
rankles Stephen King they don't want to
have to guess or prize out that context
I was working hard at conveying
emotional context through gesture and
inference rather than anything more
obvious the editorial push was to work
those emotives in which I did although
with some
discomfort I have no ill feelings about
that there was enough unusual challenge
ing elements in the novel that anything
we could do to ease the path was
probably a good thing Over time however
and through the subsequent books I have
worked back to something close to my
original style one I am most comfortable
with I think I can get away with it now
since by this time my readers know how
to read my stuff specific to dead house
gates there were eight years between
writing that one my writing my first
draft of Gardens of the Moon um eight
eight years spent writing contemporary
fiction finding a publisher for Gardens
was a huge boost to my confidence and I
set about writing dead house gates with
a sharp focus on what I wanted to
achieve furthermore I felt I could build
from the introduction established by
Gardens even though the setting takes a
sharp shift also dead house gates felt
tight from the very start very
deliberate word by word whereas Gardens
begins with more of a wild ramble and
only tightens up towards the end and
even there it's with a Sly wink quite
different from the tone of the
conclusion of dead house gates I wanted
to get effing serious with dead house
gates years ago I had a mentor observed
that my writing was not immediately
inviting in tone and theme but rather
than fight it myself I should Endeavor
to take the reader by the hand gently
even when my ultimate intention was the
drag to drag that reader into hell he
gave good guidance I think the more a
writer writes the more the writer
realizes just how how manipulative
language can be musing on it though I
don't know if dead house gates opens by
taking anyone by the hand unless it's to
snap a shackle on the wrist which act
actually is pretty accurate but I knew
the opening scene was a vocative and the
first few lines to my mind still stand
among the best openings among any
novels so we we get a good bit of you
know reflection on what's going on in
the composition of these two novels now
let's turn to looking at World building
clearly there's World building happening
in the narration in the Tale in what's
going on with these books there was a
controversy a while back that was
spurred by m John Harrison who wrote In
His blog every moment of a science
fiction story must represent the Triumph
of writing over World building World
building is dull world building
literalizes the urge to invent World
building gives an unnecessary permission
for acts of writing indeed for acts of
reading World building numbs the reader
ability to fulfill their part of the
bargain because it believes it has to do
everything around here if anything is
going to get done above all World
building is not technically necessary it
is the great clomping foot of nudism it
is the attempt to exhaustively survey a
place that isn't there a good writer
would never try to do that even with a
place that is there it isn't possible
and if it was the results wouldn't be
readable they would constitute not a
book but the biggest library ever built
a hallowed place of dedication and
lifelong study this gives us a clue to
the psychological type of the World
Builder and the world Builder's victim
and makes us very
afraid now in uh the Pat's fantasy hot
list interview in 2007 Ericson has asked
needless to say a multitude of people
disagree with Harrison's postulation
what's your take on Harrison's post and
the concept of World building in
general so here's what Ericson had to
say I wrote my response to that question
some time ago I've pasted it here two
observations come to mind the first is
that with 40 Years of reading in the
genre of fantasy and science fiction I
cannot recall one instance of a writer
committing the flaws as described by
Harrison so either I have been extremely
lucky or he has been profoundly unlucky
it is unfortunate he did no examples to
support his assertions making any effort
at rebuttal all the more difficult in
fact the only writer who comes to mind
who might be said to have gone overboard
in his world building is James Mitchner
and of course he set his novels in the
real world the second observation is
this every writer World builds in every
genre including contemporary literary
fiction and indeed when writing
nonfiction as well so he's going all in
on on the idea of World building he says
World building is nothing more than uh
there we go nothing more or less than
the selection of details surrounding the
characters establish a setting and with
it a place in which to immerse those
characters in the story of their lives
it is necessary essential to
storytelling further is he asserting the
notion that there's something uniquely
flawed when World building is in the
fantasy or science fiction genre
suggesting perhaps that the process is
somehow pure when electing to write
Tales set in our contemporary world if
so that would be an
extraordinary laughable
conceit then he gives two examples of
World building in the Contemporary world
he talks about a biography of a Child
Soldier from Sierra Leon the setting
exists as real as any other in this
world yet the narrative relating the
author's harrowing life there is
anchored in the details he relates scene
by scene event by event is this a
perfect rendition of life in Sierra Leon
we can presume it's close but we also
accept it is
selective founded on personal
experiences it is a world built by built
exclusively on relevant details
recollected by one person at a time and
a sequence of
places he says isn't this world
building says the other book also
concerned Africa and recounted a
lifelong exploration of the continent
and its peoples by a Polish journalist
once again he builds a world selects his
details to support his various
interpretations of places events and
cultures this too is selective and
subjective this to is
worldbuilding the point is as far as I
can see it Harrison is beating a straw
dog in the narrow definition of World
building he provides um he goes on he
ends up in in effect Railing at some
something that does not even exist and
if it does is exemplified so rarely that
attacking it is pointless for what it's
worth I see this as yet another example
of how the internet can legitimize
virtually anything anyone chooses to say
even when with a moment's thought it
becomes clear that what is being said is
at best irrelevant at worse nonsensical
and fatuous and then he says I'm just
responding to the quote I've not read
Harrison if he does not World build in
his fiction he's unique in the history
of literature and should be canonized
and then he ends this is very
interesting I am not interested in
joining some ferocious debate ferocious
debate did take place regarding this not
with Harrison not with anyone else with
an opinion so I hereby conclude my
commentary on this subject don't bring
it up
again Erikson is telling us you cannot
avoid doing World building in fiction or
even in
nonfiction and this is going to lead us
in two very interesting directions one
has to do with one of the key elements
of his stories here magic the other has
to do with being labeled as being
postmodern so in the discussion of
um magic in the cabalo the Arbol son
sonriente interview from
2023 um he's asked magic is another
great pillar of your Saga in contrast to
other visions of fantasy which exist
which insist on explaining the smallest
detail about how their magical systems
work in malison much of the way to
understand it relies on the reader
himself and the connections he
establishes do you think this is what
keeps the freshness that fantasy needs
to continue to amaze the reader to
maintain the sense of wonder that people
want in this genre do you think it is
negative to give the reader spoon
feeding Eric will say this rule-based
structured magic is just technology in a
universe with physics different from
ours using the same basic set of
functions if this then that if not this
then not that as machinery for me at
least the presence of magic in the mizon
world is all about the function of magic
in myths and legends as evocations of
not just wonder but also the presence of
inexplicable forces
beyond our understanding that said I
don't think The Originators of the
stories we all call myths and legends
were as credulous as some people think I
think they well understand the
metaphorical function of the Fantastic
in their tales as I suspect monic
devices mystery is part of our world
even if we choose to deny its gift even
if we set out to strip everything we can
of whatever mystery it possesses and
each time that's achieved something is
lost
a little bit later in or earlier rather
in juust MO interview uh again from
2018 he's asked again about uh s his
system of magic one of the most original
things in your book The Guardians of the
Moon Moon is your system of magic how
did you conceive of your Warren and how
did you tie them to your Gods so Erikson
will say it developed
organically we were adapting the game's
magic system in something we wanted to
explore in the fantasy world World
Warren are in a sense PLS of existence
but they also had aspects so if you
think of the four elements that the
Greek would speak about fire air water
and Earth we sort of attached magic
capacities to the things and called them
Warren then we added Shadow and light
life and death they were all aspected if
you draw on the warrant of life you can
do things like healing but we also want
the magic system to be a galarian so it
was based on discipline research and
determination magic was there for being
available to
anyone as anthropologists we thought how
does that change the cultures around
them it occurred to us it would create a
culture without a gender bias so there
would not be gender-based hierarchies of
power you would not maintain them
because there would be no way to impose
a power structure on either the genders
so it became a world without sexism and
that was very interesting to
explore uh he's also asked about the
different races and in Gardens of the
you include different races which
sometimes live thousands of years why
did you choose a timeline so wide and he
says both Cameron and I as
archaeologists we can come to a
landscape and we can see the depths of
time in that landscape we wanted a sense
of depths of time running back through
this world as well so there are layers
of existence layers of experience going
back thousands of years what made it
interesting was that there are
characters who actually experience all
those layers then we could explore the
long-term views of humanity quite often
that's a difficult thing for each of us
to do because we have such short
lifespans we can only think in terms of
maybe one or two generations but imagine
somebody who can think in terms of
10,000 years what is his view on History
what is their view on The Human
Condition that's worth
exploring now we shift a little bit
before we get into the postmodern issue
there were comparisons of course between
Game of Thrones and book of the Fallen
particularly
given that Game of Thrones Song of Ice
and Fire George R Martin was adapted to
television in the light speed interview
in
2013 it seems that the success of HBO's
Game of Thrones has brought a large new
group of readers to Epic Fantasy have
you witnessed any shift lately in the
popularity of that that genre now notice
what Erikson says here
brilliant it's funny because people sort
of predicted that with Lord of the Rings
films and then with Harry har Potter and
all the rest what tends to happen is
what I've called exceptionalism and that
is where an individual is sort of
extracted from the genre in which
they're writing and the popularity of
the genre actually becomes less relevant
than the individual I think if anything
is going to have that kind of effect of
popularizing Epic Fantasy it's probably
going to be computer games and console
games as for myself I'm constantly
frustrated by most fantasy computer
games for the simple reason that the
stories are just lacking I've dealt with
some companies that wanted to do maleson
stuff and became aware that from their
point of view they want 80% action and
20% story and I guess in many respects I
want it the other way
around we could say the same thing about
television
too in Jon Mo interview uh your type of
fantasy is an epic one with creatures
and Magic since the very beginning of
Gardens of the Moon why did you choose
this kind of fantasy and not a hard
fantasy one like Game of
Thrones Erikson says what we wanted to
do Cameron and I was exploring what a
world would be like if it had magic and
actual Gods once you do that you sort of
realize that we have a tradition here on
Earth that match that kind of thing that
kind of things like homeric stuff The
Iliad the ads The Odyssey gilgames and
maybe even Beowolf these stories take
the presence of God spirits and monsters
as a given that makes your sensibilities
very strange to us when you we read them
because we think did these people
believe these stories they were telling
or did they take them and turn them in a
metaphor and symbolic meaning did they
actually think these things exist in a
literal sense by exploring and creating
a fantasy world where these things did
exist in a literal sense we could
explore some aspects of the human
condition that we can't get directly in
this world it's almost as if through the
Malazan series and the fantasy world we
created we could reexamine things like
be wolf gilgames and the Iliad at least
I could and I find that quite
fascinating because it allowed me to
dispense with my skepticism about the
settings of The Iliad and all the rest
that was really quite
enjoyable Game of Thrones and a lot of
traditional epic fantasy often create an
eurocentric kind of sense ability it
would be a fantasy version of Europe one
of the things we wanted to avoid was
that whole idea because sometimes you
could end up bringing across an
assumption from this world to the
fantasy one we wanted to dispense with
these assumptions the main one for
eurocentric Fantasy setting would be
patriarchy and we did not want
patriarchy in this world another
assumption would be that there are
barbarians to the north there are hordes
to the east there's a decaying South all
these things that can get carrying
across to a fantasy setting which we
Cameron and I even in our game didn't
want an it we didn't like that it's just
bringing the Prejudice across with with
this world it's very much a kind of
colorblind World by doing so we can
invent cultures very specific to the
geographic regions without having to
think about earth-based cultures that
would be similar we can invent our own
and this leads us into thinking about
you know how what they're doing is is
under some rubric
postmodern so in the light speed
interview
2013 uh he's asked in interviews you
said that you're glad people are talking
about your work as an example of
postmodernism what sort of conversations
have been going going on around that he
says well basically I'm having an
argument with a scholar who studied my
stuff whereas I'm calling it postmodern
he's calling it poststructural we sort
of acknowledge each other's points but
neither of us budge I mean there's a
strong post-modern element to a lot of
the narrators within the malison series
in other words they're aware that
they're telling a story and they're also
aware that they have the option of
manipulating that story Kupa I think is
one of the best examples of that he
narrates within the story including
applying the third person Viewpoint to
himself and so you can sort of sense
he's messing with everyone's heads and
they may be the character's heads but
they're also the readers heads and
that's a reflection of how I'm
approaching it as a writer as well that
one is aware there is manipul running
all the way through this Z he's asked so
why does that critic think your work is
poststructuralist Ericson says you'd
have to ask him the thing with Scholars
they don't really want the authors
around it sounds weird but it certainly
seems to be the case we're far better
off as far as the scholars are concerned
if we've been dead for 20 years it makes
it easier to build up a thesis without
it having contradicted by the person
whose work it is and I think there's
sometimes this assumption that the
author is entirely unaware what they're
up to and that's certainly not the case
with me now we should pause here on a
moment uh and and talk about this notion
of postmodern so let let's put aside
crazy kooky culture War you know
postmodern is always bad sort of things
and let's also put to side people are
like the postmodern is good it's it's
wonderful
Erikson is working from a notion of the
postmodern I would say that includes
certain elements for example having Nar
narrators who know that they're
narrating a story and that language can
be manipulative and the postmodern in
this sense is sometimes you could say
activist saying ah what if we had a
world without patriarchy but it's not
doing so in a programmatic
formulaic activist way it's just saying
let's actually do this let's see what
happens let's project it outward there's
all sorts of other things elevating the
stories of the people who have been left
out of the elite brackets to do the
storytelling that's in some respects
postmodern but in other respects it's
kind of good fiction good realism good
philosophy that's built into things and
so we're going to see a lot of
interesting elements that could be
called
postmodern that play a central role in
these
works in the uh cabalero Arbol rente
interview much of the power of the
Malazan novels lies in the cultural
richness and racial background that Ian
esselmont and you built it offers us a
broad view of the different culture and
social forms that may exist something
that's still not very common in fantasy
perhaps still too attached to settings
close to Medieval Europe do you think
this wider perspective is what seduces
fans of The Saga so much and Erikson
says I don't know schooled in
anthropology I suppose we had a sense
that the real real world wasn't
exclusively a product of Europe and
European thinking its value systems
World Views and all the rest and that
history wasn't anything like that either
we're a complicated species and all our
cultural assumptions are diverse by the
time the novel started getting published
both Cam and I had already traveled a
lot it was the kind of travel that
forces a reset of the Mind perspective
became a tool for our fiction but that
challenge to perspective came from our
life experiences in the
World once your eyes are opened to other
possibilities you can't close them again
whether this is was or is instrumental
and how our works are valued or
appreciated isn't really something that
I can
answer then he's asked about the tan
imas these Warriors from a previous race
who turned themselves into living
corpses and he he uh he's asked about
that what inspired you and Erikson says
subverting the Trope of the undead was
consistent with a desire to subvert as
many tropes as we could again another
typically postmodern idea subversion
right working with something keeping it
partly in place modifying it showing the
hidden potentials of it taking into
account the first visual impact of aan
imas more or less invites the reader to
certain assumptions and dismissal about
their nature specifically the reader is
invited to see them as monsters but mon
ERS in the malison world are never what
they seem are they this is kind of our
Point assumptions about the other are
invariably
simplistic in uh the interview in 2011
with Owen Williams he's asked Malazan
Book of the Fallen consistently
withholds information I think that's one
of the most divisive things about the
series that's where you shed the readers
who don't understand that they're not
supposed to understand or just hate it
your dinosaur race are Masters ofch
technology are be are you being
deliberately contrarian Erikson says yes
I Delight in wrong footing readers I
know it's perverse I know it pisses some
off so badly they turn away and never
come back to which I can only shrug as
for withholding information it's more
down to holding to a particular point of
view tight with a single character at
any one time seeing only what they see
knowing only what they think they know
and believing only what they choose to
believe once that becomes the rule it's
inevitable that information is not
forthcoming that info dumps are
practically impossible and where
attempts are made the voice an imperfect
point of view makes them unreliable and
often flat out
wrong now notice what he's going to say
here this is really quite interesting
and this has to do again with the theme
of the
postmodern this isn't just the fantasy
world of malas it's our world day is in
day out every effing moment in fact
given that what people are complaining
about while I suspect the ones
complaining are the ones looking at a
fat fantasy Tome as a means of escaping
from the confusion and overwhelming
complexity of real life alas I don't
deliver on that I just drag this world's
crap over into that one mess with a few
rules of physics and whatnot and sit
back and watch that's not contrarian but
it is I suppose subversive especially to
the tropes of the genre but there's no
way I can make the claim to being the
first to do so the most powerful example
of this I know is of course Steven
Donaldson's Chronicles of Thomas
Covenant the unbeliever our crappy world
and one miserable life dragged into a
Fantasy Realm that's probably the most
subversive fantasy series ever written
breathtakingly jaw-droppingly so from
what I hear people either love it or
hate it too just like with my stuff I
feel privileged for that company and I'm
going to pause here for a moment and
just say you know if you think about
tolken Lord of the Rings Lord of the
Rings is complex and murky and the
characters are often misguided and
misled about how things actually stand
as well in that it's not as if there's a
nice beautiful fantasy genre over here
prior to people like Steph Donaldson or
or um stepen Erikson who are you know
subverting the genre it's always been
there and we could say this about Ur l k
Len and so many others as
well in the light speed interview in
2013 um we get this really interesting
observation I was reading some
discussion of your books online and I
thought it was interesting how a couple
people mentioned that a lot of your
characters even commoners have these
long philosophical discussions and some
people were questioning how realistic
that was and so here's what Ericson has
to say some of the smartest wisest
people I've met here I'll give you an
example there was this guy who was hired
with his shotgun to take care of our
camp in bise on an archaeology dig no
education no teeth and yet if you would
sit and talk with him this guy thought
about everything he kept himself
informed about world events and had read
a whole series of books on philosophy I
think the Assumption I've been fighting
against it for a long time in terms of
creating characters is that one assumes
a level of intelligence or lack thereof
on the basis of class and I don't see it
I've never experienced it quite often
you won't get those heavy conversations
with somebody who's struggling to stay
alive but at the same time if you were
to somehow sit down on a park bench and
start talking you might be surprised
it's easy especially as a fiction writer
to fall into that kind of class-based
thinking where you pigeonhole people and
create characters who are minor
characters with very little social
standing and you give them no brains I
suppose it would be easy to do it that
way but I'm definitely not into that and
I've talked to soldiers veterans who
think a lot about what they're up to so
I don't find it in any respect unusual
and again certain kind of postmodern
approach there everybody's stories could
in fact not just be interesting or
valuable as information relators but as
agents as people who have reflected
people who have thought people who use
their life experience and what whatever
they happen to encounter to engage in
philosophical you know thinking
reflection whatever we want to call it
and can share that with others in the ne
uh neoplus interview he's asked um you
kept us grounded with the soldiers where
in the process did you and cam come up
with the bridge burners with that the
presence of Munitions humani Gods
smackers you make a choice not often
seen in this mode of fiction why a focus
or interest in sappers or was it just
another element as a former combat
engineer this is something that
immediately caught my eye not only in
the books but in this interview as well
Stephen Ericson says the notion of
Munitions probably arrived as a
counterweight to sorcery a means for
non-magic practice and characters to as
you say level the field we were also
drawn to the grim and often miserable
world of the foot soldier one you see
very rarely explored in most fantasy
fiction it was always the rulers and
leaders and great Heroes leading the
mass ranks never that blurred anxious
face in the ranks themselves armies were
fodder something to end up strewn on the
CH churned up bloody fields of History
real or imagined to me such victims
represent the most tragic element to
large scale combat it's their lives that
are ruined by the desires and Ambitions
of their
leaders the victims are where my
compassion finds a home for both Cam and
myself it's where our emotion our
empathy is most fully engaged that may
be in the end what makes them so
compelling and entertaining I've been in
enough airports down in the states to
see soldiers returning from Iraq and to
see in the eyes of them something
blasted wounded and it breaks my heart
and you feel something like that in the
end of dead house gates seeing what
happens to some of these characters
you've been following this entire time
like dzer the historian who meets his
his end after so much struggle the one
who is carrying things forward and this
is where we're going to end again in the
cabalero de Arbol sonriente
interview one of the central themes or
light motif of The Saga I find very
fascinating is the
unwitnessed as an expert of History you
know well that what is recorded often
has little to do with what really
happened do you intend to emphasize the
value of decisive events or moments that
history never fairly captures or
outright forgets in its brainy
books here's what Ericson has the
say the notion of unwitnessed developed
over time as the series went on as I
continued exploring the notion of
heroism which is generally understood as
valuative an action must be witnessed to
be judged as heroic or not heroic or
maybe not can it not also be said that
many unwitnessed acts can in essence be
identical to witnessed acts deemed
heroic and does that not make them
intrinsically heroic in other words can
the valuative stand outside of being
witnessed and if so how does that even
work well it can only work through story
wherein an audience asserted as being
outside the world within the story act
as invisible and unacknowledged
witnesses to acts within the story and
within the story world that are that
that are then judged as heroic it's a
shifting of the focus to the nature of
story itself and an implicit
acknowledgement of audience as an
integral component to the whole
thing and I think that this com out so
so strongly in what happens in dead
house gates at the very end where we
have um you know the chain of dogs
um making it at least the refugees and
the
soldiers and the fist have been left
behind and they're going to be wiped out
in front of the gates of the city that
they've done so much to take everybody
to and we find that um already false
stories are being circulated around uh
about that and um you know we see that
the historian himself is going to be put
to death so a lot to think about there a
lot that's contributed to us by these
wonderful interviews
with step Erikson where he Reveals His
mindset his orientation his goals and
his
purposes there are many themes that we
could consider of philosophical depth
and importance woven into these two
malison book of the Fallen Novels and
perhaps one of the most interesting one
is in part signified by talking about
the ascendants these powerful being
beings that are at odds with each other
and often working at Cross purposes and
intrud into the Affairs of human beings
and the other races that are still
around within this world and I think we
could extend this further to thinking
not so much about freedom and
determinism because that's not really
raised you know is everything faded do
we have any control over our lives as it
is in other fantasy series of similar
scope to this but
rather what is it that people do
when involved with faced with the more
powerful the in some cases Divine in
other cases we could say
diabolical and I think it's helpful for
us to look at some some of the passages
in which we get to
see characterizations that are taking
place of the relations and the choices
and actions and so I've got a number of
passages selected to look at and the
first one comes up right at the
beginning of the work when the Fisher
girl is going to be uh taken over by
cotillon or the Rope of the House of
Shadow and uh what we see here is that
shadow throne and the hounds and
cotillon are all
there and this Fisher girl is there
after the hounds have killed this all
these soldiers so cottian says
um using my name amanus means you've
just decided for me we can hardly leave
her here now can we and uh Amana says of
course we can old friend just not
breathing Cilan looked down on the girl
no he said quietly she'll
do and then Cilan says it's going to
take a little time and then ammana says
and have we time true Vengeance needs
the slow careful stalking of the victim
have you forgotten the pain she once
delivered us Line's back is against the
wall already that's the Empress of
malison she might fall without our help
where would be the satisfaction in that
coan's response was cool and dry you've
always underestimated the empress hence
our present circumstances no we'll need
this one Lin's raised the IR of moon
spawn and that's a hornet nest if there
ever was one the timing is
perfect then
um
she's asked have you a name and catian
says enough she's not some mouse under
your paw amanas besides I've chosen her
and I will choose her name as
well and uh she pleads for her her life
I've done nothing my father's a poor man
but he'll pay you all he can he needs me
in the twine he's waiting right now and
catian says have no choice anymore child
after all you know our names and what
ends up happening the Shadows Whirled
out to engulf the girl with a cold touch
her mind fell away down into darkness
her last fleeting sensation was of the
soft wax of the candle in her right hand
and how it seemed to well up between the
fingers of her clenched fist she is
possessed by Kotian of the House of
Shadow the
Assassin um a little bit later on we are
you know seeing what's what's going on
in the battle between the army of
Malazan and the Mages along with them
and um an alliance that has been formed
against them so here we
go uh drawing her cloak against the
chilled tatter saale paused outside the
tent and turned to study the enormous
Mountain hanging suspended a quarter
mile above the city of pale she scanned
The Battered face of moon spawn it's
name for as long as she could remember
black ragged as a black and tooth the
basalt Fortress was home to the most
powerful enemy the Malazan Empire had
ever faced high above the Earth Moon
spawn could not be breached by Siege
even laine's own Undead Army the Tani
MOS who traveled as easily as dust on
the Wind were unable or unwilling to
penetrate its magical defenses pale's
Wizards had found a powerful Ally tatter
sale recalled that that the Empire had
locked horns with the moon's mysterious
Lord once before in the days of the
emperor things had threatened to get
ugly but then moons spawn withdrew from
the game no one still living knew why
just one of the Thousand Secrets the
emperor took with him to his watery
grave the moon's reappearance here in
gabachas had been a surprise and this
time there was no last minute reprieve a
half dozen Legions of the Sorceress
Tista Andi descended from Moon spawn and
under the command of a warlord named
kodon brood they joined forces with the
crimson guard mercenaries together the
two armies proceeded to drive P back the
mala's Fifth Army which had been pushing
Eastward along the northern edge of rivy
plane for the past four years The
Battered fifth had been bogged down in
Black Dog Forest forcing them to take a
stand against brood and the CR crimson
guard it was a standfast becoming a
death sentence but clearly kodon brood
and the tiande weren't the only
inhabitants of moon spawn an unseen Lord
remain in command of the Fortress
bringing it here and sealing a packed
with Pal's formidable
Wizards so we're going to find out who
this is uh quite soon and there's
something quite interesting happening
there it's going to be an
ascendant we have another character
who meets an ascendant uh not long after
that and this is pan pan opened his eyes
to Bright hot sunlight but the sky above
him was wrong he saw no sun the yellow
glare was sharp yet sourceless heat
gusted down on him with oppressive
weight a moaning sound filled the air
not wind because there was no wind he
tried to think tried to recall his last
memories but the past was blank torn
away and only fragments remained a
Ship's Cabin at the thunk of a dagger as
he flung it again against a wooden post
a man with rings hair of white grinning
sardonically he rolled on one side
seeking the source of the moaning sound
a dozen Paces away on the flat plane
that was neither grass nor Earth Rose an
arched Gateway leading to nothing I've
seen such Gates before none so large I
think as this one none looking like this
thing Twisted upright yet from his
position sideways the gate was not he
realized Made of Stone bodies naked
human figures carved likenesses no oh no
the figures moved groaned slowly red in
place flesh blackened as if stained with
Pete eyes closed and mouths open with
faint endless moans pan climbed to his
feet staggered as a wave of dizziness
ran through him then fell once again to
the ground something like indecision a
voice said
cooly blinking pan rolled on his
back above him stood a young man and
women twins the man wore Loose silk
clothing white and gold his thin face
was pale expressionless his twin was
wrapped in a shimmering purple cape her
blonde hair casting reddish glint it was
the man who'd spoken he smiled without
humor down at pan we've long admired
your his eyes widened sword the woman
finished a smirk in her tone far more
subtle than say a coin don't you think
the man's smile turned mocking most he
said swinging his head to study the
ghastly edifice of the gate don't pause
here it said there was a cult once in
the habit of drowning victims in bogs I
imagine Hood finds them aesthetically
pleasing hardly surprising the woman
drawled that death has no taste so where
is pan he's been killed and he's at the
Gate of Hood the Lord of death of house
death pan tried to sit up but his limbs
refused the command he dropped his head
back feeling the strange LOM yield to
its weight what has happened he rasped
you were murdered the man said lightly
pan closed his eyes why then have I not
passed through Hood's gate if that's
what it is we're meddling the woman
said now we find out who it is open the
twins of chance and my sword my untested
blade purchased years ago with a name I
chose so
capriciously what is open one from me
only this stumbling ignorant thing you
call your life Dear Boy The Trouble with
ascendants is they try to rig every game
of course we Delight in
uncertainty oops the man said come to
make certain of things I'd say we'd best
leave sister sorry Captain but it seems
you'll pass through that gate after all
maybe the woman said said her brother
rounded on her we agreed no
confrontation confrontation messy
unpleasant I despise discomforting
scenes besides the ones who come don't
play fair then neither do we the sister
snapped she turned to the gate raised
her voice Lord of death we would speak
with you Hood pan rolled his head
watched as a bent limping figure emerg
from the gate wearing Rags the figure
slowly approached pan squinted an old
woman a child with drule on its chin a
deformed young girl a stunted broken
trell a desiccated TI Andi oh make up
your mind the sister said The Apparition
cocked a death head the grin of its
teeth stained muddy yellow you have
chosen it said
unimaginatively you are not Hood the
brother scowled bones shifted under
creaking skin the Lord is busy busy we
don't take kindly to insults the sister
said The Apparition cackled then stopped
abruptly how unfortunate a mellifluous
deepthroated laugh would be more to my
liking ah well in answer nor does my
Lord appreciate your Interruption of
this natural passage of a
soul murdered at the hand of a God the
sister said that makes him fair game and
what what is the god
catian the creature grunted sh shuffled
close to look down at Pan the eyes
sockets glimmered faintly as if old
pearls hid within the Shadows what open
it asked as it studied pan do you wish
of my Lord nothing for me the brother
said Turning Away sister even for the
gods she replied death awaits an
uncertainty hiding deep within them she
paused make them uncertain the creature
cackled again and again cut it short
reciprocity of course the sister
responded I'll look for another a death
premature meaningless even The
Apparition was silent then the head
creaked in a nod in this Mortal shadow
of course agreed my shadow pan asked
what does that mean precisely much
sorrow alas The Apparition said someone
close to you shall walk through death's
gates in your place no take me instead I
beg of you be quiet snap The Apparition
paos makes me ill so what ends up
happening is pan is saved and will live
me not just another day but many another
day and we see a confrontation here
between two of the ascendants one of the
House of death and the other one of the
spoilers you could call it a little bit
later we get to see uh another ascendant
and it turns out that there's a whole
bunch of these great
Ravens um and the great Ravens have a
lord uh they work for the Lord of of the
Moon she says I am Crone eldest of the
moon's great Ravens whose eyes have
looked upon a 100,000 years of human
Folly hence my tattered coat and broken
beak as evidence of your indiscriminate
destruction I am but a wing winged
witness to your Eternal
Madness and um she's going
to tell the uh baroo my Lord is
possessed of honor and courtesy I shall
call him then and baroo says yes do so
um and who is that Lord going to be it
is the great ascendant who is running
the uh
place um the son of Darkness Moon's Lord
an amander rake of house dark
going on um we get to meet rake uh
coming to see Baro in the the city uh uh
you know and explaining some things that
are going on he says um here we
go
um City there was a city within Moon
spawn
I cannot defend an entire Moon rake says
I cannot be everywhere at once as for T
Shen he didn't give a damn about the
people around him I thought to dissuade
him make the price too high to save the
home of my people I retreated leaving
pale the city to fall baroo shut his
mouth cursing his lack of tact rake
merely Shrugged I didn't in anticipate
I'd face a Full Assault my presence
alone had been keeping the Empire at Bay
for almost two years
you've asked to meet with me an an
amander rake and so here we are what is
it you wish for me an alliance the
moon's Lord answered with me personally
no games baroo rake's voice was suddenly
cold I'm not fooled by that Council of
idiots bickering at Majesty Hall I know
that it's you and your fellow Mages who
rule the city
darestan I'll tell you this for the
empress your city is the lone Pearl on
this continent of Mud She wants it what
she wants she usually
gets baroo reached down and plucked at
his frayed edge of his robe I see he
said in a low voice pale had its Wizards
rake frowned indeed yet baroo continued
when the battle was was begun in Earnest
your first thought was not for the
alliance you made with the city but for
the well-being of your moon who told you
this rake demanded baroo looked up and
raised his hand some of those Wizards
managed to escape they're in the city
rake's eyes had gone BL black why I want
their heads rake replied
casually why and the answer is when the
moranth Army came down from the
mountains and Tashan rode at its head of
his wizard Cadre and when word spread
that the Empire claw had infiltrated the
city the Wizards Of Pale fled I
dispatched the claw when they were but a
dozen steps within the wall had the
city's Wizards remained the assault
would have been repelled tesen was
preoccupied with other
imperatives so he says I pulled the Moon
Back mere minutes from its destruction I
let it South drift South and went after
those Wizards after them I track down
all but two I want those two preferably
alive but their heads will suffice so
what we see is an alliance shifting and
beginning between this ascendant and the
city those who actually run this city
and are fighting against Mal
on later on we get to see what has
happened through the possession of
Cilan this is um Whiskey Jack and uh
thinking about quick Ben and Cam and
this girl
sorry what had pulled a 17-year-old girl
into the world of war he couldn't
understand it he couldn't get past her
youthfulness couldn't see beyond to the
cold murderous killer behind those dead
eyes as much as he told his Squad she
was as human as any of them the doubts
grew with every question about her he
could not answer he knew almost nothing
about
her the Revelation she could manage a
fishing boat had come from seemingly
nowhere and here in Duran she'd hardly
acted like a girl raised in a fishing
Village there was a natural Poise about
her a measure of assurance more common
to the higher educated classes no matter
where she was she carried herself as if
she belonged
there did that sound like a 17-year-old
girl no but it seemed to match quick
Ben's assertions and that Gall him how
else to match her with that icy cold
woman torturing prisoners outside nathal
log he could look at her and part of him
would say young not displeasing to the
eye a confidence that makes her magnetic
well another part of his mind snaap shut
young oh no not this last she's old she
walked under a blood red moon in the
dawn of time this one her face is the
face of all that cannot be fathomed and
she's looking at you in the eye Whiskey
Jack and you'll never know what she's
thinking why not because she is
possessed by an
ascendant finally quick Ben whiskey
Jacks Mage uh one of the uh famous
sappers is um meeting with one of the
Lords the king
of the house the house of
Shadow
and we find that he's meeting with
Shadow Throne shadowkeep Rose from the
plane like an enormous lump of black
glass fractured with curving planes
rippled in places with some Corners
glistening white as if crushed the
largest surface facing them a wall he
supposed was modeled and dull as if it
was a the weathered surface of
obsidian they arrived and The Wizard
exclaimed in Surprise as blind stroe
into the stone and disappeared he
hesitated and baron came as close to
nudging him as quick Ben allowed he
walked up to the model Stone and held
his hands and as he stepped into it and
who does he meet
there the Lord of it as he approached he
saw the figure seated there it seemed
composed of almost translucent Shadows
vaguely human in form but hooded
preventing even the glint of eyes still
quick Ben could feel the God's attention
fixed solely on him and he barely
repressed a shiver Shadow Throne spoke
Shawn tells me you know the names of my
hounds quick Ben stopped before the dis
he bowed I was once an acolyte within
your temple Lord the God was silent for
a time then he said Is it wise to admit
such a thing wizard do I look kindly
upon those who once serve me but then
abandon my ways tell me I would hear
from you what my priests
teach to begin on the path of Shadow and
then to leave it is rewarded by the Rope
meaning I am marked but for
assassination by all who follow your
ways Lord yet here you stand wizard
quick Ben bowed again I would strike a
deal Lord the god giggled then raised a
hand no dear Shan strike not quick Ben
stiffened the black Hound stepped around
him and ascended the dis she lay down
before her God and eyed the wizard
blankly do you know why I just saved
your life wizard I do Lord Shan wants
you to tell
me shadow Throne loves
deals so that is um part of what's
what's going on there um can you
actually deal with a God and the answer
is yes because these gods are ascended
humans at least some of them are
now in uh dead house gates we get to
meet some other
interesting characters like this by this
time catian has uh let sari go she's
actually taken on a different name aslar
the goddess of Thieves and is connected
with crocus who is the coin bearer of
the Twins and now
um here in this section we get to see um
them talking about about the shadow cult
and this high priest of it and uh
there's a little bit of reflection
here be calm cotillon is done with
possessing the last the bane of an
amander rakes threat remains who wants
the crude conveyor of civilized Mayhem
crashing through the temple door not
Shadow Throne not the patron of
Assassins she is protected still besides
which clian finds no further value in
using her and indeed the residue of his
talents still within her gives cause for
secret
concern right so they are uh relating
what's going on there and then shortly
after that they talk about the house of
the azath and here we're going to get a
very interesting
Revelation so they're they're talking
about the these houses and it turns out
the house of the azath exist all over
the place they're connected by one
Warren and they are as old as time
itself you might say
so there this is part of what's being
said there's the old story that the
emperor and Dancer oh hood hood is of
course the Lord of death this is a swear
Kellen VOD and Dancer aminos and Cilan
the possible linkage with Shadow this
Temple Fiddler shot isarel pus the
priest of Shadow a sharp look the high
priest sported an avid grin his eyes
glittering uh the legend goes that kenad
K kalanad and Dancer once occupied one
such house in mala's City dead house
ikariam said from the doorway the legend
is true I fidler mother then shook
himself well enough in any case it's
quick Ben's belief all such houses are
linked to one another via G Gates of
some sort and travel is possible and so
they they're relating this now it turns
out that the emperor and Dancer were
killed but also ascended they are the
shadow throne and the rope catian that
we've met
earlier um a little bit later we're
going to see something uh quite
interesting um Shadow Throne is talking
to this demon apt right and um what's
happened is 1300 mizon children had been
staked out there on crosses by the
rebels um and all of these are all these
children's bodies are now gone The
x-shaped Wooden Crosses were bare with
only stains of blood urine and
excremental to show that living beings
had once hung from them in agony in the
darkness the plain was strangely alive
with shadows flowing sourceless over the
motionless
grasses why well as it turns out that
apt the demon has um Wanted all of these
children to be in some respect saved
right and so colam did as well so Shadow
throne says to her am I a cutter A
Healer is cotillon a kindly uncle are my
hounds farmyard skulkers and orphans
puppies have you gone entirely
insane apt spoke in a rapid rasping
series of clicks and hisses of course
cam wanted to save them the shadow
Throne shriek but he knew it was
impossible only Vengeance was possible
but now now I must exhaust my powers in
healing a thousand mimed children and
for what a Spoke again servants and
precisely how big do you think
shadowkeep is you one-armed imbecile the
demon said nothing her slate gray
multifaceted eye glimmering in the
Starlight Shadow Throne hunched suddenly
as Gau like cloak wrapping cloak as he
hugged himself an army of servants he
whispered servants abandoned by the
Empire led to their Fates at the hand of
shikes bloodlusted Bandits there will be
ambivalence in their scarred Mal Souls I
see long-term benefits in your
precipitous AC Dem and lucky for you and
there's one single boy who is going to
be uh saved uh who's who's sort of
special in that Bunch um a little bit
later we um find that there's um fison
is
um who's who's had a very terrible uh
path um she's been raped and abused and
stuff like that she's actually going to
become the next shik the she's going to
be possessed by the Whirlwind
itself right and so what we see
Happening Here is um she's she's
essentially a
rebirth of this figure who's been going
from body to body a Cascade of thoughts
swept through fison as she climbed into
the stone platform shik reborn that dark
clo of dry which is the Whirlwind
descending felisin Noble born Brad of
utna of the mining pit open the
holy book and thus complete the right
that young woman has seen the face of
the Abyss that terrible Journey behind
her now comes the demand that she face
the one before her the young woman must
relinquish her life opening the holy
book yet who would have thought the
goddess so amenable to a deal she knows
my heart and that grants her the
confidence it seems of deferring her
claim on it the deal has been struck
power granted so many Visions yet
fessing remains her rock hard scarred
Soul fre floats free in the vast
Abyss fesen stepped past the giant din's
power trickled into her ah dear goddess
precious Patron do you now hesitate in
your gifts like this crowd like leoman
do you await the proof of my words my
intent and then she has this engagement
with the Mages and then she thinks the
Whirlwind was nothing but preparation
for this the this the raising of drena
star standard the spear that is the
apocalypse a standard to Tower over an
entire continent seen by all now at last
the war begins my War so she's opposing
the Empire she's also opposing her
sister who is the new uh adjunct to the
empress and we're going to close with a
scene from almost the very end of dead
house gates where the empress is
encountered and Kalam the Assassin has
gone in and is ready to kill her and we
find out something else so the empress
is
not uh an ascendant she is a human being
but the most powerful human being in
terms of her command of the perhaps the
world at that
time so it turns out that there was a
plan in
mind
so she tells
him here we go the outlawing of dujac
the high fist was is a temporary measure
a ruse in fact we perceive received the
threat that was the panonian uh panon do
doen duuk however was of the opinion he
could not deal with it on his own we
needed to Fashion allies of enemies
Kalam we needed dustan's resources we
needed kaladan brood and his rivian
Bargas we needed alamander rake and his
TI Andi we needed the crimson guard off
our backs now none of these formidable
forces are strangers to pragmatism one
in all they could see the threat
represented by the p SE and his Rising
Empire but the question of trust
remained problematic I agreed to D DJ's
plan to cut him and his host Loose as
Outlaw as they are in in effect
distanced from the Malazan Empire and
its desires our answer if you will to
the issue of trust kalam's eyes narrowed
in thought and who knows of this ruse
only duj and Tashan the High Mage who
betrayed the other
Mages he heard the smile as she said ah
well he remains in the background out of
sight but there for duj should one arm
need need him Tashan is Dux how do you
soldiers say it his shaved knuckle his
as we say Ace in the
Hole colam was silent for a long minute
the only sounds in the chamber were his
breathing and the slow but steady drip
of his blood onto the flagstones then he
said there are older crimes that remain
the Assassin frown the only sense
assassinating Kellen VOD and Dancer I I
ended their rule of the Malazan Empire
usurped the throne a most vicious
betrayal in truth an Empire is greater
than any lone mortal including you
including me an Empire enforces its own
Necessities makes demands in the name of
Duty and that particular burden is
something that you as a soldier must
certainly understand I knew those two
men very well colam a claim you cannot
make I answered a necessity I could not
avoid with reluctance with anguish since
that time I've made grievous errors and
judgments and I must live with
those and so he leaves the empress
doesn't kill her as he'd intended to
she's still in place so what we see here
are all of these very interesting
intricate plots and interactions of
these powerful beings but and if we had
the time to go into further
philosophical themes we would also talk
about all the little people involved as
well and the solidarity that some of
them show with each other but I think
we're going to have to wrap this up here
because we've already exhausted so much
time in discussing this one
philosophical theme we will be
revisiting the novels
in this series coming back to the third
and fourth in the next uh session of
this and perhaps down the line will'll
go through 5th through 10th as well but
for for now this suffices to bring our
study of these two great malison book of
the fall and novels to a close and I
hope that if you haven't read them that
you check them out really wonderful
fantasy and if you have read them
hopefully you've resonated with and
responded to some of the things that
we've discussed in this
session